o lado disse que ouviu um barulho de
fora meu lado disse que quem fala é
outra que estejam muito em mim diz é
mais um vídeo e o estado de queensland
tennis 3 mil para gritar o que vamos
cruzar em que o uso pessoal
[Música]
estou num dia cheio do sol é obviamente
está no item pessoal não sabem que a
gente também está no vez nem por isso
só que aí vamos lá estou a viajar ipce
lala.com hotel é bissexual não via muito
serelepe silvan tava mais três da manhã
prever esta série é uma série muito
épica e supostamente era para ser um
jogo de tudo ou não é
mas pelos vistos está muito animado e o
solo tal não sou eu brutal e vamos lá
então falar aqui com o deep senão este é
o tim k ex vou lhe dizer um ao apronto
haitink aí pô
isto é ficar com fome é o cão diz ok
vamos lá para dentro 1 a fazer tipo
tarde eu acho que castrar da equipe
tarde ou assim ok mas eu acho que
deveria falar com a aula primeiro ela
está um pouco em baixo não fique assim
lá eu vou animar lá eu estudei entanto
para caraças
ok olá pouco que que eu vou perguntar se
está tudo bem se ela quer brincar ou é
deus não acho que podemos ir ainda
ficava mais triste por isso vamos lá o
que estás bailar lá eu tive um pesadelo
na última noite é o cara era sobre
coisas más que aconteceram mas eu não
consigo lembrar ok préstimos ditador
méxico foi apenas um sonho tempo
esqueceu aproxima as mesmas hipóteses ok
então pronto vamos brincar lá ela diz
que não lhe apetece muito brincar por
isso olha é deus não quer fazer nada a
deus é uma pessoa ruim o alex uma pessoa
rude ok supostamente para entrar aqui
olha aqui a bola dela que cláusulas bola
e evitar o gol de love se faz alguma
coisa nem o twitter ainda mandar a bola
pro fundo eu sou mesmo mal vamos entrar
em uma casinha e ver o que tem aqui
dentro eu é que um solo é brutal a sério
lembro em tom bem desta série
entre houston a yoki a entrar aos sol
outra coisa
todas as decisões que tomar neste show
vão afetar a história por isso é eu vou
tentar fazer sempre as coisas pelo lado
bom sim é o lab psi já em contraste o
chapéu vou perguntar esta primeiro caiu
diz que não que ainda está perdido e eu
não consigo lembrar um de queixo chapéu
eu vou encontrar eventualmente eu tenho
certeza ok então pronto eu vou perguntar
agora como é que ativa a máquina de dois
netos carregar no botão olhem à direita
agora lembro obrigava-os vai então meu
mestre manuela não há pouco anda mais
rápido pela manhã ela teve um botão
então agora está ativo
agora posso fazer touch eu não sei
exatamente câncer é tarde o tipo white
não sei bem mas pra mim sempre foi tarde
estava talvez pra mim sempre comeram
partes fazem uma tarde manuel fumagalli
o pronto já tá aí a china a china é a
china é é a máquina estava estragado
através de não conseguir ler o resto
rápido eu estou cheio de forma precisa
encontrar tempo mal muito boxe tipo 1
uma é é uma caixa de ferramentas isso ok
vamos lá então a procura na máquina e
não da caixa de ferramentas
é um enorme diferença é isto
anders torce o que eu fosse lá e tocar e
tem de haver aqui alguma coisa a equipe
era lá é isso encontrar encontra
encontrei em que está pra quem é esse
a loa assim em doha estamos contentes e
lá é que não parece muito contente mas
pronto ok faz um humano uma tarde não
consegui ler eu acho que vou conseguir
fazer pra mim mas tenho suficiente pra
vocês
acho que é assim ok então vamos lá fazer
aqui start
ela está triste voltar a la primeiro
expressa outra coisa meu conforto ao
insulto a cair novo insultar-se não
ela ainda fica pior eu vou fazer sempre
o bem
ok eu fiz uma uma tarde para ti espero
que sinta melhor é obrigado por tudo
isso um verdadeiro amigo país ou lá
estamos cometendo não é olhar nem
conversa lá tentará agora uma tarde é
que o tim hill inc e olhe psi música
mudou de repente a ficar cozza
agora é preciso fazer uma tarde pra mim
mesmo
dez horas depois de dormir rock começou
a jorrar água é captada noite todos
deitados ok não consigo dormir
agora com o autor diz do órgão ana lá
a máquina estava ligada aparentemente
não estava acesa pucca quintal e caraças
que não faça mais essas coisas caem para
chegar eu pensei que você vai construir
uma marca assim não é uma mistura de
cantar para lá
é o que está a fazer vai pra cama porque
tarde o protesto a máquina caiu que está
a fazer pronto eu acho que a melhor
pergunta susto
para ser justo mas apareceu aqui
o decreto está já ir em auxílio da casa
meu filho da manhã partiu a máquina em
cima da casa
o cara está uma decisão é acordar os
outros ou seguir o team quilón quero vos
quero tempo em que lo porque sou
corajoso e não quero que os meus
companheiros morrão ok não há tempo para
acordar os outros eu preciso seguir um
rápido antes que eu vá para longe
ok é melhor eu agarrar uma tocha é que
tá na mesa de trabalho uma tocha não era
flash lite que encontrar porque
exatamente tem que avisar foi o item
seguir agora o coiso o tempo em que é
isso eu confundo sempre anda lá é
painéis
campanha não é isso exatamente toca
agora tudo faz sentido porque destaca
que essa fonte há oito anos lá embora
meu era por onde a área porque porque
agora está a ficar tenso é a ficar tenso
chegou tesoura que excluindo e tevez não
anda lá ok só vou ser eu estou a adorar
esta história está apenas uma vez para
continuar a segui lo ou por onde é que
eu deveria ir
acho que esquerda à direita ao cair só
vocês já sabem vou sempre pela esquerda
e como eu disse
toda a decisão vai influenciar a
história por isso não sei se é a opção
mais certa um mês
ok tem que o inc do estado por aqui eu
acho que não vai responder nem eu acho
que eu nem sequer fala agora o tempo em
que não parece estar aqui é melhor é
melhor haver perto do lago
acho que é isso o que vamos ter que
seguir um lago então por cima dele
indicação é ali que ficou lá por isso
vamos correr pela padaria apesar de
estar da noite não é ok go
estamos na área também quase a chegar ao
lago já chegamos a ouvir as notícias só
sabia mesmo
agora aquilo que é que o ok ele é casa
fosse fosse a nossa casa nós vamos ter
que pôr a nossa casa outra vez
supostamente não é eu estou atrás de mim
a voz nervosa eu fosse com a esposa só
que cheguei fiéis quem eu estou morta
lote
alguma coisa está errada com as artes e
rocks foi isso foi obra do start com
isso não volte atrás levando para dentro
da casa opera
fernandes não quer conhecer ou mandam
muito direta eu acho que fui casqueiro
foi uma coisa assim
aí tem que ficar lá cozido e virar à
direita é isso é isso mesmo em si mesmo
a cair eo aproxima agora parece me
aproximando e isa também já apanharam o
centro adalah ok agora pra baixo e voz
mais fácil como futebol como é que eu
não morri nesta manhã os técnicos
trocaram muito rápido
não não a companhia agora eu não sei por
onde é construir isto e provar através
da ravina quero ver que em cima de mim
meu tem muita ação este jogo tem muita
ação eu não concordo se os planetários
dois de um tipo móvel campanha se era só
no ar não é assim que nós temos que
procurando está errado para antever as
coisas mas não sai não sei o que
aconteceu agora
além de tevez 3 em breve este foi o mote
da campanha aqui dos clash tevez ea
versão demo por para além disso existe
muito mais
ah eu não sei quando é que vai ser um
jogo completo mas eu curti paquerar
sistema espero que vocês deixem o vosso
feedback nossas leis são sempre leva a
sessão os amores
então é isso que o flick favorito fiquem
bem até a próxima
[Música]